who in the world is admiral greenball
how do his seemingly limitless powers
work and will he turn out to be an enemy
or an ally to luffy's and the straw
hat's cause we have been waiting for the
reveal of this man ever since dressrosa
where doflamingo revealed that the
marines had drafted not one but two
power houses for the vacant admiral
positions left by aokiji and akainu and
now after many years of starving to see
what this man's power looks like with
oda sensei feeding us nothing but a
silhouette or two here and there we
finally have seen what the third marine
admiral next to kizaru and fujitora
looks like and is capable of and my god
is he capable now i can't be the only
one who'd love to be as strong and fight
just like greenbelt and while i sadly
don't have his devil fruit for you to
eat i have today's sponsor to help you
out with just this dnf duel dnf duel is
a new and exciting dueling fighting game
that has just now released on ps4 ps5
and pc and it's packed with a lot of
great character design lore and much
much more this game reworks 17 years of
iconic dungeon and fighter history into
a whole new experience and even though i
honestly don't play a ton of fighting
games usually it was super easy to pick
up and get obsessed with i really love
the anime like art style and the
controls feel incredibly intuitive so if
you also feel the urge to fight dnf dual
is now available on ps4 ps5 and pc on
stream so check it out now using the
link in the description below green bow
or aramaki as he's actually called is a
tall muscular man with shoulder long
black hair a pair of badass looking back
shades and smoking a cigarette which
funnily enough goes kind of against his
otherwise pretty green image he's
refusing to wear a shirt under his
admiral code rightfully so i mean i
wouldn't wear a shirt either if i had
that upper body strength and he carries
an incredibly sleek looking katana
without any sheath but simply jammed
into his belt so i just stabbed myself
there anyways he has a massive kanji
tattoo on his chest in order death river
heart middle the last two kanji together
read shinju which means double suicide
committed by lovers but it can also mean
one's true feeling or true motives so i
guess the tattoo reads something along
the lines of lover's suicide on the
river of death while it might also hint
at aramaki having hidden true motives
compared to what he openly says i want
you to remember that because it will be
important in just a second when we talk
about greenbow's true intentions he also
wears really tight pants with a sakura
motif on them going very well with his
plant-themed powers now you will have
noticed i think that aramaki in general
has an incredibly japanese vibe around
him just like the actor hara da yoshio
who was famous for his ronin and
gangster roles that he is inspired by i
think that green bull has pretty strong
yakuza vibes the straight blade no shirt
under a jacket sunglasses and the
cigarette
this is meant to be a classic japanese
gangster and it once again brings up a
really interesting and honestly
important question that people have been
asking for quite a while now is aramaki
from wano because while the world of one
piece has a lot of japanese influence
simply because it's written by a
japanese author predominantly for a
japanese speaking audience there is one
place in particular that is fully
centered around edo period japan and
japanese culture that even has the
yakuza as an actual institution and that
place is wono this was also speculated
for fujitora by the way or isho as he's
called who also has an incredibly strong
samurai theme and as we know both of
them not only got drafted together but
they also seem to get along really well
and talk like old friends and so
honestly what other place in one piece
could you possibly find such randomly
powerful people to draft into an admiral
position than wano the one country the
world government has never dared to
attack because of its powerful warriors
and that even a kainu doesn't want to
send troops to remember the admirals are
the most powerful force that the marines
have at their disposal the top tier
fighters they have to face people like
whitebeard or shanks the original three
admirals were shaped into these monsters
over decades within the marines so
really the effect that they drafted
someone from the outside into this
highest of positions really speaks for
their power i think oda sensei has
actually more or less confirmed in an
sbs that fujitora and green bowl share
similarities and might have ulterior
motives that go against the world
government both isho and aramaki have
been ignoring direct orders from a kainu
multiple times and fujitora even
abolished a warlord system that was one
of the government's most prized
balancing powers in the world one very
intriguing possibility is that fujitora
or ryokugyu or maybe both of them are
former daimyo or yakuza bosses that had
left wano before or when kaido took over
the country and so a number of clues
that people like my good friend mr morge
have identified actually suggested that
green bull might have been shimotsuki
ushimaru a man who has an actual bull on
his coat as his symbol and has the word
ushi which does mean bull literally as
part of his name by the way in the anime
the bull on ushimaru's coach is
literally green literally a green book
the very same shimotsuki ushimaru that
now has been heavily suggested to be
either zoro's father or at least some
sort of relative one awesome example
that morge brings up is how both zorro
and ryokugyu are introduced as fasting
with both luffy and fujitora commenting
on it yokogyu says that he would only
break his fast for a pretty girl and
zorro literally breaks his fast to eat
the little girls onigiri that helmepo
has made fun of and stomped on now after
knowing what ryokugiwu and ushimaru
looks like your first reaction might be
the very same as mine these two look
nothing alike at least that was my first
genuine impression but then i took these
two images of the two and put them
together in photoshop and you know what
it works like do you see what i'm seeing
the eyebrows and the eyes match up
pretty much perfectly the nose is
exactly the same his mouth not only has
the same expression but even the
cigarette and the grass straw are in the
exact same position the only real
difference really is the hairstyle that
let's be real is probably really easily
changed and also don't forget that 20
years have passed between that scene in
the cave with yamato and today and so if
i had to bet any money on who admiral
greenbeau truly is i would absolutely go
with shimotsuki oshimaru who also is
zoro's father and i think that that
would explain everything we have seen
from greenville so far absolutely
perfectly of course he would come right
back to wano after kaido's defeat he and
the other daimyos tried fighting back
against kaido and his armies but were
defeated he probably joined up with the
marines in the first place due to his
hatred for pirates and what they did to
his country similar to how fujitora
couldn't stand doflamingo's unjust rule
over dressrosa i mean they might have
joined the marines to finally defeat
pirates like kaido in the first place i
actually think it's quite possible that
both green bull and fujitora only got
their respective devil streets also when
they joined up with the marines and were
drafted as admirals greenball ignoring
akainu's orders and coming to wano to
see what's going on anyways would be
only logical if it's actually his home
country not only would you want to make
sure that the beast pirates are actually
taken care of for good which is
literally the very first thing he does
when arriving but he would also want to
make sure that no other pirate just
hates kaido's place which is why he's
planning to take luffy's head as well he
would want to see a free wano not simply
one tyrant replaced by the next because
as far as aramaki knows luffy is a
wanted dangerous criminal and he hasn't
met luffy yet luffy who now has a
ridiculous three billion berry bounty
very much unlike what we here on this
channel have with 61 million 100 berries
for each subscriber so rather than
becoming a yonko our big goal is
fighting hard to overtake the slimiest
man in all of one piece who for some
reason has a bounty of 99 million please
go help me win this fierce race to 100
million berries by hitting subscribe and
getting freshly baked one piece content
every single week now my biggest
argument for green bowl loving wano and
hating the beast pirates for what they
did however is this panel from chapter
where we see udon prison from afar
compare this panel here where we first
get introduced to the prison as it's
surrounded by a deadly wasteland to this
green bull is literally reviving wano
and returning all of its lushness and
nature he uses all of the beast pirates
energy to rejuvenate wano and he's doing
that to all of the country as he's
making his way from udon to the flower
capital this isn't just a random side
effect of his powers because otherwise
we would have seen flowers and plants
just spring up all around him on
marijuana as well no i think this is
green bowl actively using all of the
energy he has absorbed to do this and
green up wano and so the question really
is what will happen once green bowl
actually reaches the capital because i
personally think that he is quite
serious about taking luffy's head
aramaki seems to be no big fan of the
world government just like fujitora but
that is also true for akainu as well
there's a lot of movement in the marines
right now to reform and become
independent from the governments
including people like garb kobe x-drake
but also the fleet admiral himself and
so i think that green bull can be
against the world government but still
pro a kainu supporting his style of
leadership and trying to get his
approval and this actually caught my
interest as well as you might know the
admirals follow a very interesting color
scheme you have the three primary colors
red yellow and blue that you can use to
mix any other color with mixing red and
blue for instance gives us fuji tora's
purple and i think fujitora's justice is
indeed located
somewhere between akainu's red and
aokiji's blue incredibly strict and
merciless like a kainu but open to
exceptions and reason like in luffy's
case similar to aokiji in that sense
green bull would be a mix between aokiji
and kizaru incredibly powerful and
destructive when unleashed as we could
see but also pretty laid back and
curious like kizaru was on sabbahood
this goes very well with greenball's
relaxed nature that we also saw on
marijuana when he was hanging out with
fujitora and so should greenball
actually turn out to be ushimaru however
in other words zoro's father that would
instantly solve my one big issue with
the ending tiwano so far zoro's
unresolved connection to the country so
greenball's solo arrival at the flower
capital might very well be exactly that
zorro meeting his father and either
learning about his heritage or he might
already be aware about it and simply
recognize his father depending on how
young he was when he got separated or
abandoned by his parents i think an
admiral crashing the party in the
capital like aokiji kind of did during
water 7 would be epic enough by itself
but this sort of connection would make
it even better than it already is by
itself honestly but let's also talk
about aramaki's powers by themselves
here for a bit because just how wood is
incredibly overpowered in the world of
naruto they seem to be incredibly
overpowered here as well not only can
green ball build any structure with his
powers he is literally able to take life
energy and redistribute it by growing
plants of any type this seems just
ridiculously powerful even by admiral
standards it also really makes me wonder
what type of devil fruit this actually
is my first reaction was to categorize
this as a paramecia or special paramecia
fruit being able to generate plants with
his body but at the same time the fact
that he can drink sake through the roots
and steal powers from other for himself
almost makes it seem like his body might
be made from plants as in he might be a
plant logia fruit user i'm just super
curious to find out what his actual
devil fruit is called and categorize
that and of course find out more about
his true intentions and what he's like
as a person since we just found out that
momo's grandfather kozuki sukiyaki is
alive as well if greenbull is a former
daimyo he would surely recognize him as
well and so no matter what way you look
at it greenbelt's introduction together
with the reveal of the new yonko has
changed the power dynamics of the one
piece world fundamental and if you want
to understand what that means for the
future of the one piece world you really
shouldn't miss this video right here